look at that jacked mm-hmm you're a big
dude but I could take you
whoa that looks like [ __ ] James Bond
me not all these other [ __ ]
he's my all-time favorite James Bond
like far that's a real James Bond yeah I
know I like his like yeah I like his
steely resolve my other favorite James
Bond is a potential James Bond adavi the
James Bond yet it's Idris Elba Idris
Elba and because white people are mad
yeah it's like fantastic for moving they
got like maybe Jordan it's like everyone
just calm down look at that right there
oh good lord laid his body look at that
barf look at that there's me he's
already kind of got a little little like
he's got the beginning of man tits yeah
I mean he's not bad it's better than my
fat it's just he doesn't look like a guy
who fought with a [ __ ] sword for a
living yeah but that's how they that's
probably close er like more accurate to
what you know what actual like Romans
and you know not if they were actual
gladiator there an actual gladiator they
had a swing swords around look at that
arm
come on son then army carrying those
swords just lean muscles lean muscle
guys wiry yeah something's coming out
bro he's jacked but yeah this is Kubrick
people who people always forget yes kuba
can't confirm that but yeah that's a man
yeah I apparently hated it too like
Union he hated the movie yeah it's
probably one of those things he had to
do yeah 60 yeah jeez god I loved his
movies yeah yeah no this is actually one
of the weaker ones really
you ever read The Shining no it's really
interested in Steve and King did not
like it
yeah oh the movie not like the movie
because they did the TV movie yes like
in the early 2000s we got Stephen
Williams Steven Weber yeah and he just
decided that you know like Kubrick had
made Jack Nicholson crazy already yeah
and he didn't like that yeah and he
wanted a guy that was turned Korean
crazy by the house yeah yeah but how the
[ __ ] you gonna do that and to
you know what's not scary hedges you
know like there's a thing it's like it
probably like you know I bet you if you
know you read it or whatever it's
probably seems creepy like when he's
like talking about how the hedges are
moving when he's not looking in
something that but when you physically
see it it's not scary at all
you know what I mean like yeah like it's
just like things like that like just a
thing don't really translate but it
worked in the book the books amazing the
books really it's a big-ass book too
it's Stephen King I mean you know yeah I
think it's a big-ass book yeah there's a
confusing it with the The Dark Tower
series there's also the stand is really
thick yeah it's a dictionary paperweight
he was I mean it still is but so [ __ ]
pearl if there's a thing with the at the
mazes it's like yeah like the mesas
keeps on kind of like changing like the
one the one that you see in the model
there and the one that exists and
there's also a map on the outside of it
all three of those are different bushes
and get a look from the top I think it's
like kind of more like stems I don't
think they're like thick branches just
hack your way through walk straight yeah
that's true where the bushes what are
you scared about the mushroom come on
well the hedges that are moving you know
in the book so monsters mm-hmm yeah
they're it's kind of like you know these
like like Edward Scissorhands
esque like kind of like you know it's a
kid yeah it's like and then it's like oh
it's moving when you're not looking like
oh that's an adorable cat hedge that um
that place that would that's supposed to
be the Estes Park is that what it's
supposed to be that area was supposed to
be somewhere in Colorado that's like
that yeah I mean I think that's where
they filmed it or at least the you know
the outdoor some of it I think they
filmed some of it also in upstate New
York yeah yeah like yeah but it again
and then you'd like a studio I think I
think it was from London usually Kubrick
worked in out of London
but yeah the Overlook Hotel there we go
yes yeah it actually is like it's not
called the Overlook it in real life but
yeah it's in Colorado yeah that was a
[ __ ] great movie yeah so creepy and
weird so many of your eyes wide shut
that was another one yeah that's and
that's his last movie yeah a lot of
people didn't like that one I thought
that was fast
you know I'm a little soft on it like at
least when it comes to like I mean it's
still great right I put it lower on
my Kubrick um yeah Clockwork Orange 2001
I mean like it again you name it
you know it during his spare time he
used to do complex mathematics that
sounds about right
yeah it was like a legit genius yeah
he's a archives in I think it's in
London but there's actually disdaining
Kubrick like library and if she can kind
of go through his scripts and his notes
and all kind of stuff look you know
there's some you know like a whole like
archive but it's supposed to be kind of
pretty neat